[Music]
welcome back Bayless with us again from
Barren Wisconsin where she's covering
the dramatic return of Jamie class
few people will ever be able to
understand what Jamie is going through
right now and what she has to contend
with in the days to come someone who can
understand is Elizabeth Smart in 2002
fourteen-year-old smart was kidnapped
from her home in Salt Lake City Utah she
was held captive by a married couple in
their home for nine months before being
rescued Smart is now a child safety
activist and she joins us this morning
from Park City Utah Elizabeth good
morning good morning it's so good to see
you and Jamie's family is telling us
that she's doing as well as can be
expected but based on your experience
what are some of the motion emotions
that she may be feeling right now well
right now is a very sensitive very very
important time for her to sort of
rebuild those connections with her
family I mean she her family's been torn
apart in such a brutal way that now is
just vital that she has that time with
her family to reconnect to rebuild that
foundation to have that support so that
she can move forward so this so that she
can move on with her life
it's incredible to hear some of the
details that are just coming out about
Jamie who's just 13 what does it take
mentally and emotionally to try and
escape the person who is holding you
captive I mean she's just incredible
what she's been through and how she was
able to escape and she's truly a hero
Elizabeth I know that the sheriff just
told us that you've reached out to him
and that you've reached out to the claws
family as well they were all very glad
to hear from you what did you want to
say to them well I want them to know
that anything I can do I am more than
happy to help them and I admire them all
and I feel like everyone loves and
supports them and wants to help them in
every way we can and at the same time I
think it's really important that we all
give them the space and the privacy that
they need to to rebuild their foundation
now one thing that you said that that
really struck them was that Jamie is not
going to be the same person that she is
different now and that she has to start
her life anew
now I also remember something you said
that your mother said to you when you
returned home can you share that please
with the audience absolutely my mother
told me after I returned that what these
people had done was terrible and there
weren't worth strong to describe how
wicked and evil they are they'd still in
nine months of my life that I'd never
get back with the best punishment I
could give them was to be happy was to
move forward and I think in Jamie's case
the same is true I mean she will not be
able to go back to who she was before
she was kidnapped I mean she will never
be able to just return to life before
but that doesn't mean that this that's
what has happened needs to destroy her
future or needs to define her future and
Elizabeth as within your case this has
really brought the community together
what can those around Jamie do now to
make sure that they treat her in a way
that's respectable that's respected and
that she feels confident in moving
forward and not bad the way you were
sometimes were made felt I think it's
really important and I was with any
victim to really think about the way
that you speak to victims and if you ask
questions really think about what you're
saying because for years whenever people
would ask me oh you were brought down in
public before and why didn't you run and
why didn't you scream for years I my
brain didn't actually hear that question
when it would hear the words why didn't
you I actually heard you should have
which made me feel guilty which made me
feel like I didn't do enough to survive
when in fact I'm not ashamed of anything
I did because ultimately I survived and
I'm here today and the same is true of
each and every victim you said that even
making small choices for Jamie is
important for her recovery why is that
well I was kidnapped I didn't get to
decide when or what I ate or drank or
where or or where I slept or what I was
able to wear and all those decisions
were made for me I felt like I was
completely powerless
so when I came home having the ability
to make choices again I mean even small
choices like what cereal light for
breakfast or what shoes I'm gonna wear
that day those that was a big deal for
me because I was so controlled Elizabeth
do you want to meet with Jamie in person
I would be happy to meet with Jamie in
person but that being said if she wants
space and she doesn't want to talk to me
that is completely fine I will never I
will never presume to push myself upon
anyone so much wisdom so much that
you've already shared with us and I know
can help her so we thank you so much for
joining us this morning Elizabeth Smart
thank you thank you and the family is
hoping that that meeting does occur